roselyne bachelot vous avez souvent
affirmé que vous ne reviendrez y est pas
en politique pourquoi avoir fait ce
choix de revenir dans la classe
politique
bonjour j'ai sorti c'est toujours cette
phrase je ne reviendrai pas en politique
sauf si on me proposait le ministère de
la culture
donc quand on fait une citation pour la
première chose
donc ça c'est une raison je dirais
personnel mais au delà nous sommes dans
une situation où on peut pas se défiler
devant les responsabilités
la france vient de subir un choc
économique social et sanitaire de toute
première grandeur
il ya des gens qui sont dans un état
épouvantable
les artistes en particulier bien
d'autres aussi mais les artistes les
créateurs le monde de la culture a été
totalement à l'arrêt moi qui suis une
femme de culture je vis ça dans ma chair
est évidemment dans mon coeur donc j'ai
pensé que je ne pouvais pas me défiler
devant cette responsabilité et que si je
peux apporter quelque chose à mon pays à
sa capacité de création à son
rayonnement
c'était le moment de sortir de mon petit
confort personnel mais justement vous
parlez de ce secteur culturel en crise
est-ce que vous pensez que le
gouvernement en a fait assez pour
soutenir ce secteur culturel certains
disent qu'il fait partie des grands
oubliés de la crise alors je ne peux pas
laisser dire cela immédiatement mon
collègue franck riester a pris la mesure
de tout cela il y a évidemment le
secteur un secteur qui avait déficit de
toutes les mesures générales d'urgence
le chômage partiel les pauses emprunt
galets prêts garantis les fonds de
solidarité ça représente quand même pas
loin de 3 milliards d'euros
des mesures spécifiques on pense au
fonds d'urgence pour le spectacle vivant
il y a eu effectivement d'autres mesures
qui vont
arrivé en fin qui sont déjà arrivés
comme des mesures spécifiques et puis on
prépare un projet de loi de finances
rectificatif qui va à nouveau mobilisé 1
06 milliard d'euros avec des
dispositions fiscales des dispositions
sociales de des crédits budgétaires
directs et puis s'ajoutera évidemment
quelque chose qui tient très à coeur au
président de la république cette année
blanche pour ce qu'on appelle les
intermittents techniciens ou artistes
qui bénéficieront jusqu en août 2000 21
des dispositions dérogatoires de
dispositions dérogatoires qui vont
permettre de bénéficier de
l'intermittent alors ce n'est pas
suffisant parce que le choc a été
terrible mais dans le plan de relance il
y aura aussi des dispositions nous
sommes en train de discuter avec
d'autres ministres puisque on sait bien
que le président de la république a
décidé c'est peut-être une première que
le plan de relance serait économique
social environnemental et culturel alors
un mot sur votre retour ici au sénat
vous arrivé un peu en terrain conquis
car vous connaissez une partie de la
majorité de droite ici au sénat en
terrain conquis je ne sais pas si je
reviens au sénat en terrain conquis je
viens plutôt sénat en terrain à
conquérir à conquérir par mon action à
conquérir par mon implication
rien n'est jamais gagné au sénat parce
que les sénateurs il ne vous juge jamais
sur des paroles il voulut sur des actes
alors effectivement j'ai retrouvé
beaucoup de visages amis et ça ça fait
toujours très plaisir mais ce n'est pas
ça qui m'attend c'est de gagner des
arbitrages ces deux voilà et puis
d'avoir le soutien des sénateurs de tous
bords j'ai toujours su fracturé les les
frontières politiques j'espère que je
continuerai vous allés fracturer les
clivages comme emmanuel macron
comme roselyne bachelot très bien merci
beaucoup roselyne bachelot d'avoir
répondu à mes questions
[Musique]